the dolphins not in trouble they're at
seven and four rebounding from a very
bad start to the 2019 season brian
flores addressing the media today on the
question of whether
it will be tuatanga vailoa or ryan
fitzpatrick at quarterback on sunday
when the dolphins play the bengals
here's coach flores
and anytime you're dealing with it with
a
you know something that's bothering you
there is some some impact on all those
things you mentioned
um accuracy and velocity obviously you
know anytime you have a
an issue on the hand um there's there's
some impact so uh yeah obviously that
that's part of the evaluation and you
know go through it as a staff um you
know we've pretty you've gone through it
you know really throughout the entire
week and
you know both guys were quarterbacks of
practice so
you know
we got to make a decision and we'll make
a decision um here pretty soon
and of course tua tagovailoa has the
left thumb injury that's the throwing
hand struck a helmet nine days ago
didn't play against the jets and
i've got no problem with this the
gamesmanship the shell game the who are
you going to face you'll find out on
sunday even though it is the bengals you
take advantage of anything that comes
your way and yes you prefer to have your
starting quarterback healthy but if he's
not let's milk it for all it's worth and
let's keep the opponent guessing and
shireen there still is the possibility
that two is fine or close to fine and
this is just a way
to let ryan fitzpatrick play and win
games and position the dolphins for the
playoffs because they saw enough from
two in three weeks to believe that
fitzpatrick at least for now is the
better option not that they would ever
say that but that could be going on and
you were talking about that the other
day and you may be on to something yeah
yeah and that was my little conspiracy
theory that that maybe he is okay and
ready to play and there was a close-up
of his hand that was posted today and
and uh to his hand was pretty well
wrapped there and he was doing a handoff
with the hand pretty well wrapped the
thumb to protect the thumb but you know
they play cincinnati game getting the
schedule right today they play
cincinnati this week in kansas city next
week and
as you as you've talked about mike once
you've put
a high draft pick like that in the
lineup it's hard to pull him out but
when he's hurt there is that excuse that
he's hurt and they could milk this for
two weeks if they wants i don't think
you can start tua if he's okay and then
come back and put fitzpatrick in next
week about against the chiefs but maybe
you ride ryan fitzpatrick for the next
two weeks against the bengals and then
against the chiefs before you put two of
back in the lineup to close out the
season they're they're really you know
it's tough a little bit because they're
in this playoff race and it's like do
you do you get too experienced and
really get ready for 2021
or do you really go for the playoffs
when fitzpatrick probably is your best
option when you go for the playoffs so
that's what they've got to decide maybe
not the easiest of decisions but maybe
you put two back in there maybe you make
the playoffs anyway i don't know but i i
am i believe that they will play ryan
fitzpatrick this week
i'm a firm believer and i think brian
flores agrees with this approach you
always put the best guy out there you
put the best 11 on the field your teams
your players know who the best guys are
and you get yourself into trouble from a
credibility standpoint if you're doing
anything other than playing the best
players we saw that last year when josh
rosen was
being evaluated and at at one point
flores said it's going to be rosen as
the start of the rest of the year a week
later he was benched again and i think
flores knows they've got to win football
games and that's the key establishing a
winning culture worry about next year
when next year comes for now take
advantage of a rare opportunity for the
miami dolphins to be in the playoff
conversation and indeed they
are hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports